este es uno de los pocos lugares de
europa donde el oso pardo se siente en
su hábitat en lo alto de las montañas
del cantábrico en el norte de españa-
han pasado de ser una visión rara a una
atracción turística
incluso durante la pandemia unas 40.000
personas hicieron el viaje con la
esperanza de verlos y
bueno pues principalmente lo que están
comiéndose avellanas aquí llevan ya
varios días concentrados lo que hace que
es comer avellanas
el negocio más grande es algo
impresionante y bien un animal que
prácticamente se había extinguido y
llegar a esta cantidad de osos que
tenemos hoy es un privilegio el oso
pardo fue cazado casi hasta su extinción
a principios de los años 90 la población
había descendido a unos 60 individuos en
los últimos 30 años los números se han
ido recuperando lentamente hoy hay unos
400 osos salvajes viviendo en la zona
pero a medida que aumenta el número de
osos también lo hace el daño que
infligen entre 2009 y 2018 las
autoridades locales pagaron en promedio
290 mil dólares en indemnizaciones por
año hay una solución sorprendentemente
eficaz
y le dio y le pegó también
guillermo palermo dirige la fundación
oso pardo y está visitando un colmenar
local para comprobar que la valla
eléctrica funciona como es debido
y los impulsos son muy severos se han
levantado 1500 cercas en las montañas
para proteger los medios de subsistencia
estos lo más efectivos es que otra cosa
aunque pongas alambre de espino te va a
entrar es un recurso importante que hay
que cuidar y que hay que proteger porque
con el oso es la principal causa de
problemas en la cordillera cantábrica
con los ganaderos hay muy pocos
problemas la ong oso pardo está ayudando
a mantener estas vallas que en parte
paga la unión europea este podría ser el
secreto de la convivencia los daños de
la colmena representaron el 64 por
ciento del total de las indemnizaciones
pagadas en 2009 mientras que en 2018
representaron un tercio otra solución
los guardabosques de la ong plantan
regularmente árboles en las montañas
para que los osos tengan una fuente de
alimento suficiente este es el árbol del
sorbo silvestre que produce una fruta
que a los osos les gusta comer ya que la
mayor parte de su dieta es vegetariana
los guardabosques esperan que la fruta
sea lo suficientemente tentadora como
para que dejen de buscar comida más
lejos como en los pastizales si le
aportamos comida lejos del entorno
humano
estamos evitando de alguna medida lo
posible que el oso se acerca a ese
entorno más humanizada mientras tanto
los ataques de los osos a los seres
humanos son cada vez menos frecuentes
solo siete en más de 30 años
este activista del bienestar de los osos
transformó su vida para estar más cerca
del animal
estaría francés se instaló en españa
hace seis años el invierno pasado compró
un rebaño de ovejas y pronto se encontró
con unos vecinos inesperados
la familia se instaló en esa zona rocosa
de ahí arriba apenas 150 metros en línea
recta desde el granero
una madre y sus tres cachorros vivieron
aquí durante dos meses una convivencia
pacífica eso es gracias a este recinto
electrificado donde encierra a sus
ovejas cada noche esta es la valla
eléctrica
pero en otras cordilleras como los
pirineos sería difícil adoptar este
modelo ya que normalmente se deja los
rebaños vagar a su antojo
no todo lo que se puede hacer aquí se
puede hacer en otros sitios por
diferentes razones históricas y
culturales los métodos de pastoreo no
son los mismos hay que hacer cambios
pero estoy convencido de que los
pirineos podrían adoptar los métodos
utilizados aquí
en los pirineos se registraron 64 osos
el año pasado por lo que les queda un
largo camino por recorrer antes de
alcanzar a los vecinos españoles